mmm that is a technique within crowd
work of like you ask someone are you how
long you been married they're like two
years ago I've been married three years
let me tell you this and I have material
about but that's not really crowd work
that's just that's just that's just
leading into a story yeah crowd work is
to me is having a conversation
ahoy hot breath averse welcome back to
the hot breath podcast the show where
you learn comedy from the pros I am
comedian Joel Byers that is my dog
Guinness and today we are diving into
the top five crowd work tips from Ian
bagg who is known as one of the top
crowd work comics in the world so buckle
up take notes and here we go what was
the process of developing that skill set
and let's get into the weeds here
because crowd sure don't think comedians
are like scared of and they may dip
their toe me like oh never mind select
it if we could break down even just from
like a beginner all the way to now a pro
of like developing the skill set of
crowd work well first of all I think a
lot of guys are gonna I'm gonna ask this
question they're gonna say that and then
I'm gonna say this they practice crowd
work which I don't think you can
practice crowd work the only way to
practice crowd work is go to some place
and ask somebody a question and see how
they respond that's the only way you can
do it and have and I've always I've
always been that guy that's kind of just
started conversations with people in the
middle of nowhere you know even though
as I've gotten older I don't talk to
anybody on a plane or anything like that
but it takes it takes learning
conversation it takes being able to
listen to somebody to give an answer to
you know there's nothing worse when I
watch a guy do crowd work and he has the
prepared answer and hasn't heard what
they've said and it makes no sense at
all
what do you do I'm a mechanic lawyers
are dicks right yeah
have them in the chamber they'll try to
steer them into material innocence mmm
that is a technique within crowd work of
like you ask someone are you how long
you been married they're like two years
ago I've been married three years let me
tell you this and I have material about
but that's not really crowd work that's
just that's just that's just leading
into a story yeah crowd work is to me is
having a conversation having a
conversation is how long a man married
let me tell you about what yeah that's
just that's basically banter that a band
would have hey Jerry how long you been
playing the bass 14 years that's fun
remember 14 years ago we started that's
that's basically that yeah crowd work is
crowd work is when it can go sideways
and you don't care and can still make
something out of it what is the most
sideways what's the Massiah
why goes all the time like what the last
time I was here a guy was throwing
bananas at the comics before what and
then they didn't kick him out and I went
onstage it went sideways from there they
wanted to fight me like that that kind
of sideways like yeah you know yeah it's
I've had a girl pass out in the middle
of the show and hit her head like you
know I had a guy have a seizure like
that guy that the sideways where you
shouldn't you should think everything
stops but you're able to keep it the
balls moving hmm you can be concerned
about them they can be taken care of and
they leave and then you keep the show
going like that kind of sideways you
know that kind of uh I love when I say
to somebody are you married and my
husband's dead you know that kind of
thing now you got to take that and like
that goes on what people get media death
will throw real weird wrench into a show
yeah yeah so you got to be able to you
know that kind of that kind of thing you
got to be prepared for anything you know
it's like flying a plane you got to be
prepared for anything so you just and
the big thing is about making people
able to escape letting her escape from
her husband being dead if you can get
her to escape from that the rest of the
crowds gonna follow so you lean into
that when SMO yeah husbands
you like oh what'd you go like what
happened I'm like how long uh huh how
long has it been dead for sure you're
single all right you know right you
leave your money cuz I'll call my wife
right now and then BOOM yeah something
yes I'm stupid like that
some stupid but yeah some stupid but
something something to make her laugh
you know you know just because yeah
people are there to laugh to escape you
know sometimes people that they're just
not there to have fun at all which makes
me it makes me I'm just like mmm
you've been tricked into this by your
friends and you couldn't just stay in
the car while they came in and had a
great time yeah you had to you had to
bring it down for everybody but I know
it's just having fun right like if you
put out a fun energy than the audience
will kind of reflect that back to you
yeah yeah yeah and it doesn't matter if
you can be the darkest person in the
comic in the world mm-hmm if you're
having fun with it have fun like
Stanhope's he's insane but he's having
fun right right there's a reason they
get on that trip there's no word that
that he doesn't he doesn't get that if
he's cranky cranky it's not fun you know
it's fun doesn't matter you know you
know even Marc Maron who's the crankiest
son of a [ __ ] ever it's fun like his
crankiness is fun you know I mean and
he's having fun with being up so it's
it's the guys that aren't having fun up
there that don't don't go anywhere
well there it is hop read the verse the
top five crowd work tips from the top
crowd work comic subscribe if you'd like
to support the show and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips and
stop sucking at comedy go ahead click it